it is friday and there is news in the
national football league and we're gonna
get to it
uh and and one one important item of nfl
news that and let me just make this
clear we only talk about it when there
are developments there are people out
there like why are you talking about
desean watson well he's one of the best
players in the league
and he's embroiled in
a controversy that is in many respects
unprecedented and when there are
developments
we can't ignore them we have to discuss
them we have to make sure people
understand what's happening because
people have questions and people are
curious and people want to know how this
saga is going to play out so
miles here's the
first bit of news because there were
multiple developments today which sean
what's there were multiple court
hearings for the first time these cases
in court and
the first line of defense by rusty
hardin who's been hired to represent
desean watson is to try to force
the plaintiffs who are proceeding
without their names attached to their
lawsuits
to do so
and
more specifically
i think he wants them to face that
decision of do i do it
or
do i just try to take some sort of a
reasonable settlement and move on now
and step aside from this 22 plaintiff
group and let it shrink down
to a smaller group so
bottom line is
without getting into all the nuances
rusty harden has prevailed that's the
good news the bad news is rusty harden
has prevailed because to the extent that
it's going to cause
most of these folks to say
i'll just take a small amount of money
and move on right now i think the number
is 14 of the plaintiffs who are willing
to disclose their names and as more do
it what happens miles more will be
willing to do it it wouldn't surprise me
if all 22 eventually allow their names
to be disclosed because there will be
strength in numbers
right exactly and so when there are when
there is that strength in numbers then
you are at least among a group i think
one of the things that stood out to me
just from all of the developments today
is actually solis and what happened with
her that busby said you know that she
was receiving a lot of threats so if
that's one person you know and that all
of the threats would be at death threats
assault threats and all kinds of
different things that have come up if
that comes to one person then i think
what we're talking about in the strength
in numbers yes that extends to all these
women who say you know something
happened to me that is not right and
that's why i have come forward with this
suit and that's why i'm also willing to
come forward with my name to make sure
that this can go forward and proceed so
that we can get some sort of justice in
the civil justice system
and i think that ultimately what rusty
harden was hoping to do was to apply
some
settlement pressure to the entire group
i think rusty harden would like to get
tony busby to the table in a meaningful
way where they can attempt to work this
out where they can attempt to make
things right where they can attempt to
put this behind desean watson so he can
continue with his life and his football
career and i feel compelled to say this
every time the topic comes up i'm not
suggesting that this be a simple
exercise of just writing a check and
making it go away i think desean watson
has a reckoning that he needs to
experience he needs to make things right
with these individuals he needs to
understand why they believe
that the line was crossed and i think
when you get folks in a room together
and you have an experienced and skilled
mediator who is good at bringing these
folks together and creating an
atmosphere of conciliation and
ultimately settlement it can happen but
you got to get
tony busby to come to the table and my
guess is rusty harden's had a hard time
doing that because there's value in
being coy my prediction and this is a
complete throw a dart prediction
i think at some point let's say the
monday of draft week
i suspect that tony busby is going to
send a lengthy letter to rusty hardin
that articulates the case that
articulates the strengths that touches
on the broader dynamics and makes
a firm demand maybe some room to move
but not much
a demand for each client as to what
it'll take to get the case settled by
the time the draft begins on thursday
and
by then if it doesn't settle then
buzzby's approach will be we're going
forward with all of these cases and they
may hover over to sean watson for months
if not years to come that's just a guess
that's something i would consider as a
tactic to put maximum pressure onto sean
watson to resolve these cases before the
draft in the hopes that he could maybe
be traded and get on with his career in
2021.
right that was a question that i was
gonna ask you that like because you you
would think that that is the day because
it's not necessarily a drop dead date
but it's one of these dates where
it would make sense because of the draft
upcoming and because of all the ways
that the football decisions have to then
follow from what these legal decisions
are right it's something that you would
say all right it would make sense if
deshawn watson is going to get traded
then he would get traded on or around
the nfl draft because that is when picks
are flying and teams are making all
kinds of decisions so in terms of the
football calendar that's why you think
that date makes sense then
yeah and even then first of all i think
it's difficult if not impossible to get
22 cases settled before the draft it's
20 days away and it may be that tony
busby's letter needs to be initiated
sooner than later so they have a small
window to try to get it resolved and
then they have a week or two to get the
paperwork done because if i'm going to
trade for deshaun watson i want to know
case is resolved case is over no loose
ends no maybes or ifs or contingencies
they're done and the only thing that i
have to worry about moving forward is
what the nfl may do by way of an unpaid
suspension see the unpaid suspension is
always going to be there at the end of
the road
but until we get to the end of the road
desean watson quite possibly is not
going to be permitted to play
it should be just a matter of time
before with all of these complaints
against him he's placed on the
commissioner exempt list now i've argued
the nfl should do it now
the nfl's position typically is in the
offseason there's nothing to tell a guy
to stay away from so why are we creating
an unnecessary headline
and making this a point of further
discussion on shows like this and on
websites like pft let's just do nothing
regardless something i think gets done
if these cases are still lingering when
training camp rolls around so that's why
i think there'd be an impetus
to try to do something now
get him done
get him finished and see if there's a
way you can do it the right way
and then maybe there's a trade that can
be had knowing that there will be some
uncertainty as to what the nfl
ultimately does with desean watson could
it be suspended four games six games ten
games a full season i wouldn't be
surprised with all these claims
if he suspended a full season miles we
just don't know and that's part of the
risk and i was talking to somebody about
it today who's very plugged into the way
things work in the league you know
watson is good enough
that
you could see a team trading for deshaun
watson if the window opens and it's a
deal where you look at and say you're
getting a franchise quarterback for
nothing or next to nothing or a very
reasonable price if he's going to miss
all of 2021 we can live with that
because we're going to have him after
that his contract is going to toll for a
year and we're going to have him for the
next 10 or 15 years so we can deal with
one year of anticipation and not having
desean watson next year we we've got our
guy and everybody knows we've got our
guy we can market it and you know the
passage of time if he gets the proper
reckoning if he does make it right the
passage of time sets him up for
redemption and we like a good redemption
story so again it's not going to be easy
to do but
but there's 20 days to try to do
something and my guess is that watson
would like to if he could
the challenge is going to be pulling it
off
right and i think what you said about
maybe having a trade there in that team
that would acquire him saying yes all of
this
is worth it if we get the franchise
quarterback because i think i was saying
this yesterday production equals
tolerance right and we talk about that
from all kinds of different standpoints
but when you're talking about a
franchise quarterback who is an elite
quarterback sometimes no matter what
they've done
no matter how horrible it could be right
and all these things that are still
alleged out there and we don't know if
deshaun watson has done them or not but
even in the court of public opinion you
it's almost a little bit easier to sell
that when you know that you're getting a
franchise quarterback who is performed
at an elite level now whether that
should or should not be the case i think
is an entirely different issue but when
you're talking about again a quarterback
who has played at the level that desean
watson has for a couple of years now
it's reasonable to assume that a team
would make that trade because his trade
value has diminished and whether or not
he gets suspended or for whatever length
he gets suspended that team would then
say yes we now have a quarterback that
can set us up for not just next year but
or two years but potentially for the
next decade so there's a lot that i
think goes into this and there's a lot
that's going to continue to go into this
is these cases continue and as we
continue to hear from the lawyers from
both sides but there's it's just it's a
nuanced situation mike and i think
that's what kind of makes it tough to
discuss
yeah and all these teams are clamoring
for quarterbacks at the top of the draft
because they want that answer for a
decade or longer having a great
quarterback helps people keep jobs and
it helps members of the staff who don't
have the highest level of jobs get jobs
elsewhere that's what the value is and
that's why there surely our teams
carefully monitoring this looking for an
opportunity to swoop in and try to buy
low that's the key you can buy deshaun
watson's contract low if you move at the
right time and if you're willing to
stand in the shoes of the employer who
may not know what's going to happen now
what did happen this afternoon at three
o'clock eastern time rusty hardin had
his first press conference regarding the
case and
if i can summarize the attitude
accurately and appropriately the
attitude was
we don't want anyone to reach any
premature judgments about this case but
listen to all these people who are going
to come up and vouch for deshaun
watson's innocence did i
accurately summarize what happened
yeah i think that you did um especially
just from the standpoint that it was
rusty harden and then four female
attorneys who then came up and then
talked about everything that they've
learned about deshawn watson's character
there was one lawyer who came up and she
said that she didn't even know who
desean watson was before this process
started and before he walked in to her
office but then she is now convinced
that he's not capable of doing something
like this and that to me is where you're
getting into territory where you start
to really believe something about
somebody's character but character is
what we do
when nobody else is watching and
unfortunately whenever we're talking to
somebody we don't necessarily know what
anybody is doing when nobody else is
watching so that that really struck me
is something where it's like man it does
not mean that he did it but it also
really doesn't mean that he didn't do it
i think that sometimes we should take a
step back and just say we don't always
know people's character even when they
are in front of us and they are
appealing to us and they seem as
believable as can be
the lawyers are trying to score points
obviously in the court of public opinion
and you could argue that desean watson
has already been lapped multiple times
by tony busby in the court of public
opinion and there was a lot of
complaining by rusty hardin about the
things tony busby has done but at the
same time rusty harden and his team
using tactics that i believe are
disingenuous and
unfair when you're trying to say we
believe in due process we want this
process to play out and then you're
having people come up and say i don't
think he's capable of this behavior well
first of all the last folks who are
going to be testifying at the trial of
any of these 22 civil actions are the
lawyers and obviously the lawyers are
paid to vouch for and defend
the client but they want to gloss over
that because they are trying desperately
to try to level the playing field in the
court of public opinion and of course
the easiest way to do it miles would
have been to bring deshaun watson and
let him speak you saw the clip at the
beginning where rusty harden said he'd
have to he'd have to uh turn in his
malpractice insurance if he allowed
desean watson to do it and the look the
safe course of action is you never let
your client speak in any setting like
this because anything you say will be
used against you in civil court criminal
court if it comes to it but
i i feel like the time for third party
vouching has ended once one of the
individuals
tells her story
and we see the face and hear the voice
right
well
that's when i think the ship sails on
lawyers who were paid to say good things
about deshawn watson saying good things
about desean watson and what they could
have done they could have written their
own statement
with deshaun watson's input they could
have crafted a document that he could
have sat there and read and taken no
questions just like ashley solis took no
questions but we get a chance to see
deshaun watson to hear deshaun watson
and as long as the words used are words
that they would be comfortable
having attached to his story
from now until the end of this matter
would be fine could have done it maybe
should have done it because again at
this point when you have an individual
who's already given us name face and
voice
i i really am not interested in hearing
third parties vouch for the person who's
supposedly innocent i want to hear from
the person who's supposedly innocent
i agree with you mike and i think it's
not just um solice who talked it's the
letter that was read by another one of
these accusers it was it's the article
that came out um at si.com last week i
mean there are now multiple accounts
that at least have some sort of name
attached to it then like it's not just
something that's in the suit now i
believe that actually that si.com
article was still under an anonymous
name but it you understand what i'm
saying here right it's not just that we
have one person we have multiple
accounts we have multiple personal
accounts i think when you take a look at
that article from last week even that
woman was not a part of one of these
suits right she had had the opportunity
to link up with tony busby and she she
decided not to do that at least at this
time so i think when you take all of
that into account i think you're
absolutely right it's not time to just
hear from lawyers who are paid to say
that to really say the best things about
desean watson because it's their job to
prove or at least say that he is
innocent of all of these things so
that's one thing now if we hear from
deshaun watson it is another whether it
was a prepared statement or not it is
another thing when you're actually
hearing from that person and having them
say what it is that they need
i almost felt like at times the media
was being chastised
for
whatever it was that we've done over the
course of the past few weeks what we've
done is cover the case what we've done
is
reach our conclusions regarding who's
winning in the court of public opinion
because both sides have been playing the
court of public opinion and i think it's
fair to make decisions based upon
that prism that context court of public
opinion understanding that none of it's
going to matter when it's time to go to
court civil criminal or both but
look a big part of this when you're
talking about someone who has the
profile that desean watson has had for
years
a big part of this is how is the average
person going to process and react to
this information because just like a
juror who is in the box at the beginning
of a trial when the judge says you shall
not reach any conclusions about anything
until the end of the case the reality is
they do they immediately do i used to
explain to people that
it's impossible to not
begin
to at least root for assad it's like
turning on a football game involving two
colleges you've never heard of there it
is it's all i don't know i got nothing
else to watch two colleges i've never
heard of before they're playing football
i like football i'll watch it
until you start rooting for one team or
the other you really don't have skin in
the game you really aren't engaged you
want to see a certain outcome and that's
what happens to jurors at trials and
that's what happens to jurors in the
court of public opinion they get
invested they develop opinions they come
to conclusions they align with one side
or the other and so far tony busby's
done a great job of aligning
members of the public i'm not going to
say how many i don't know what the
percentage is but i feel like busby's
been more effective than harden now
something hardens said today
relating to what actually occurred a
little preview of the defense that we
may be
experiencing and witnessing at some
point as these cases unfold here's rusty
hardin admitting on deshaun watson's
behalf that sometimes these massages
became consensual sexual activities
here's hardin
deeply deeply do not believe
this guy ever did anything
non-consensual with any woman during any
of this he didn't coerce him we don't
believe he used his position we don't
usually believe he intimidated him we
simply do not
there were there sometimes consensual
encounters
yes
and
will that come out in any kind of
litigation or trial of course it will
and that's where it should come
okay
here's what we're going to have 22 cases
22 plaintiffs
other witnesses potentially who will be
subpoenaed to testify regarding
consensual activities that they aren't
complaining about because they're going
to try to get a full picture of the
extent to which deshaun watson was using
massage therapy sessions as a potential
gateway to
sexual activity and you've got the 22
individuals who
have concerns about him
plus however many others are out there
who haven't sued who won't sue who were
engaged in consensual activities and we
don't know what that number is we have
no idea we may never know with certainty
but i suspect both lawyers are going to
try to figure it out but miles here's
what it's going to come down to
desean watson admitting that at times he
has engaged in consensual sexual
activities within the confines of these
massage sessions that he books via
instagram more on that in a second
but in this case there was nothing
that involved pressure coercion use of
my profile in order to get someone to do
something they don't want to do and the
woman in each case is going to say
but you did
how do you resolve that
22 cases
how do you resolve that standoff
sometimes sometimes
massage therapy leads to sex
but not in this case that's desean
plaintiff
he tried to get me to have sex with him
he tried to pressure me into having sex
with him sometimes
sometimes yes
totally consensual
22 different individuals
saying
he tried
and it made me uncomfortable
and i was touched
and they all have different specific
accusations but it's all got that
similar thread
a massage that
this individual had designs on becoming
more than a massage
that is a tough needle to thread
22 times under the very low standard of
preponderance of the evidence miles i i
hate to use this example
but i think
it gives you an idea of how difficult
this is going to be assuming there are
22 cases
22 juries
22 instances of trying to prove this
case
this is the equivalent
to win
to be exonerated to never be found
guilty of anything when you consider the
standard is basically 5149 this is like
flipping a coin 22 times and having it
come up heads 22 times that's what he's
facing in my estimation
well and that i think just sets out just
how difficult it is
right because when you talk about the
preponderance of evidence and i think
that that is really the key phrase and
when it boils down to it and all the
legalese it just means 51 culpability so
if that is the case
then
preponderance of evidence is not proof
beyond a reasonable doubt and you know
proof beyond a reasonable doubt is what
i think most people think of when we
think of the legal system because
everybody watches things like law and
order and you know that's what you see
in the courtroom and all that this is a
completely different thing so
if you have to to do that right you have
to go preponderance of evidence and you
have to go 22 times without
proving that then like you're saying
mike that is extremely difficult
especially i think based on what we've
heard so far in the court of public
opinion and now the court of public
opinion is not a court of law but
when we think about all the different
things that we've heard when we think
about the statements that we've heard
from folks who have allegedly been
assaulted right and we think about
ashley solis and the personal statement
that she gave
then i think you're really illustrating
what it is that you're saying that you
know if you're flipping a coin 22 times
it's very difficult for it to always
come up heads
and really
these civil cases with that low standard
of basically who do you believe you're
asked to resolve this who do you believe
there's not going to be a tie here
there's not going to be a wash i mean
there could be a hung jury but the
there's no outcome on the verdict form
for draw it's either plaintiff prevails
or defendant prevails it's that simple
did the plaintiff prove by proponents of
the evidence that there was whatever the
specific allegation may be in a given
case and i know from my experience for
18 years every case i ever took to trial
could have gone either way and i know
from trial training exercises i was
involved in when you have a closed
circuit camera that the jurors who come
from the community who know it's all
fake but they get into it and they get
engaged
and you hear the things they talk about
in the jury room and you think why do we
even have rules of evidence why do we
even why do we even bother because
they're going to bring their own
experiences to the table and you get a
collection of individuals who are unique
in every case
impossible to think with any degree of
certainty that desean watson is going to
be exonerated 22 times given the
allegations that are made and given that
rusty hardin has acknowledged that
sometimes consensual sexual activity
occurred one more clip from hardin
addressing why deshaun watson utilized
instagram for the purposes of arranging
so many different massage therapy
sessions
getting two to three massages a week
the math i do on that
is anywhere from 120 to 140 to 150
massages a year
he's been here since 1918.
in the year 2020
all of a sudden spas shut down
if y'all remember nobody was getting
massages unless they came up with an ad
hoc way to do it
so that partly that it doesn't mean
exclusively he'd gone on instagram for
four to line up and he did
but i've learned but the
fact is the world massage world during
the pandemic changed if you look at
these allegations
my calculation is every one of them
occur after we shut down for the
pandemic i was in a trial so i'm pretty
mindful of when everything shut down and
everything shut down the middle of march
first one of these allegations is late
march of last year that doesn't mean
that he was never using instagram before
i'm not suggesting that i'm just saying
that if you are a busy active athlete
and you are traveling constantly as he
was
then you are going to have immediate
when you want to get one you can't
predict it ahead of time and by the way
these these football teams don't have
this battery of masseuses i think that's
probably something when you all look
into it and start talking you'll find
out it's not the case
these all these players they use
different masseuses which is another
thing that i had to learn because of the
generational aspect
millennials live on instagram
those of you who are millennials know
that those of you or not have probably
discovered it long before i
they do business on it
sean lives on instagram he does business
transactions on instagram other people
do i'm discovering a much more prevalent
use of it than i had any idea okay
are we clear we're clear so
here's
here's here's the water's there my
concern there's a lot there let me just
try to unpack two things very quickly
first of all
nfl teams do have a battery of massage
therapists they do i don't know where
he's pulling that from they do yeah they
do
they
do
okay secondly secondly to the extent
that the pandemic deprives you
of the ability to regularly be massaged
by the person that you ordinarily would
use let's assume that's true
what the hell is he doing ricocheting
around from massage therapist to massage
therapist don't you think he'd
eventually find
one person like oh i can't use for
whatever reason my regular massage
therapist during the pandemic can't use
my regular massage therapist it's a
pandemic okay fine
so you find one other one somewhere and
you use that one over and over again not
this revolving door that's where the
logic of this falls apart from me miles
well he's talking about rusty rusty
heart's talking about he's going to
different cities and he's doing this and
he's doing that and so that's why he has
to find all of these different massage
therapists you mean to tell me he's
going to 40 different cities and needs
40 different massage therapists and i
just
it doesn't track to me and i'm glad that
you brought up the thing about how the
nfl teams don't allegedly have a cadre
of masseuses yes they do i've seen them
in locker rooms all the time
everybody had i mean if you covered the
nfl you know that that is it's frankly
it's just not true and you know why
especially why we know this because they
were testing folks coming in and out of
their facilities so the with kovid to
make sure that it would be safe right we
heard about the guy who was cutting hair
for the kansas city chiefs why do we
think that we knew that the guy
providing haircuts had coveted you
really think that they wouldn't test
people who are giving massages come on
man of course they are it's because they
they there's sports science that goes
into that you know it's just that whole
that comment just struck me is so odd
and i don't know where he's getting that
from but yeah that didn't make any sense
to me
sometimes you just got to make chicken
salad out of the facts that you have and
i think that a lot of what we heard
today from rusty hardin and his
colleagues who spoke they're doing their
damn just to represent their client
let's not forget that tony busby is
trying to represent his clients
rusty harden is trying to represent his
client the individuals who spoke on
behalf of desean watson were trying to
represent his interests the truth will
come out in court but don't forget
unless these cases are consolidated and
that is a lot of eggs to put in one
basket if you're desean watson and i
wouldn't do it with 22 because at some
point it becomes an avalanche that is
undeniable by that one jury you got 22
juries you got that low standard of
proof you got to flip that coin and have
it come up your way 22 times when it's
time to go to trial i would not want
those odds if i was desean watson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports